here we go
if i can master this i can master
[Music]
anything
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
do you ever wake up and you just like
like don't you ever just
wake up coffee that's my that's
that's my thing i just don't feel like
doing anything
today do you feel like just like
joey how do you feel
in all seriousness are the stars skewed
is it the
5g tower is it the globe getting flatter
is it the plates beneath the earth
shifting what is it that causes
days where you just want to spend the
day in bed i don't know if you relate to
this but
you know maybe i'm wrong maybe maybe
it's it's just me and if you are out
there
having you know just the best day of
your life every single day you wake up
and you say whoa
i want to know your secret please baby
tommy
those people definitely don't exist i
feel like it's just impossible to never
have
an office what about me today i've got
to go to work and
i feel like like i just don't want to
work
jesus somebody woke up on the right side
of the bed this morning this is kent who
who seems to be all jolly roo over here
and this is not a depressing vlog
or a deep vlog getting into details with
freudian or paul young approach to
the collective unconscious and
archetypal structures and bio makeups
and
create anxiety and depression and all of
that
this is real [ __ ] it's raw so today if i
don't
seem over the moon and super stoked
[Music]
that's because i i just don't feel that
way really
anyways what i was saying i've actually
tried to tackle the subject
around a year ago gabs and i were
staying in midtown manhattan next to
a turret card reader gabz who believes
in the
alignment of the stars and all that sort
of stuff made me walk in and get
a ten dollar reading this ten dollars
escalated to
500 bucks by the fortune teller
convincing us
that four crystals will keep our
relationship intact
and solve the bleak like days we all
have
and once again i'm getting distracted
from the story
[ __ ] where was i oh yeah today
follow me in last week's vlog i teased
you by nearly revealing my
new factory space and introducing my new
super ambitious
intern i'm gonna take the order but i
decided to save it for
today instead so let's go inside and
then i'll get back to the point
of this vlog about days like today just
there
[Music]
[Music]
the first question on your mind is dan
why the [ __ ] do you have such a
big space firstly amongst cape town
los angeles and new york i've hoarded
a lot of [ __ ] secondly gabs is just over
it
dan how am i supposed to get my car out
of the garage
what what we even doing last night and
this
who's gonna end up cleaning this thirdly
there's still a lot of work i'm still
very active
in the film industry and a place like
this would provide
an area to service bigger production
it's a place i could turn into my kind
of andy warhol
dream factory there's going to be a
skate park there's going to be a cinema
a full music studio and a whole bunch of
other [ __ ] but but most importantly
i've always wanted a space where i can
give back and i'm going to be utilizing
the space
to educate the unsung filmmakers and
sung
heroes that just don't have access to
the right gear
in this country but as exciting as that
all sounds it's still
intent and i would rather showcase
the action and talking about something
more actionable and
purpose-driven is the idea within this
video if we go
right back to the beginning of the vlog
and you saw i was in los angeles with
way too much ambition not listening to
my own advice which has always been
learned to give up on your good ideas to
make space for the great ones where
clearly
that was a [ __ ] idea but at that point
in my life there was so much certainty
i was busy planning a big tv show with a
network i was in the development of a
feature film and then
i got struck with the coronavirus and
once recovered i returned to south
africa
and my wedding got cancelled this then
led to
a large level of uncertainty and the
frightening idea
of how quickly things can change and
even though they seem to have changed
for the beta and things have worked out
for me and i'm really really grateful
for that during this time
maybe it could have something to do with
the stars
realigning i still can't help
feeling this presence of uncertainty and
that's just what i want to be open and
honest about and
speak about and and showcase my
vulnerability because i think that it's
a discussion that we should be having
you know we should be okay with saying
i feel pretty [ __ ] right now and there's
nothing wrong with that
there's nothing shameful in that so you
know you can use the comment section
in this video to just rant type away all
your frustrations
and ideally that's what this channel's
about it's about creating
a community of like-minded people
today's been a pretty
insightful and rad day
even though it started off being a
day you guys seriously still in bed
maybe i told you we were having a bad
day today
was it a big day boy all right
in actual fact had a breakthrough that's
why
i'm recording this i assume that you
spend the whole day in bed and you feel
like
oh i feel so [ __ ] to spend the whole day
in bed yeah baby i had a really
good day admit okay well again let's
just say like
that you you had a bad day because you
were in bed
okay so my breakthrough so i went to
work
and i was like i don't want to be doing
what i'm doing right now
i don't know why but i just don't want
to be doing this through doing it
i actually had a pretty good day just
because i started
that's like the poo on your shoulder
baby you got to give it context
poo bear tattoo
this one look i love the story behind
the setting
can i tell it tell it
[Laughter]
okay so piglets and poo or winnie the
pooh
are walking along together one day and
then piglet turns and says to winnie the
pooh
what day is it today no no no it's the
other way around
you got it okay okay okay yes right
that's right yeah so piglets only the
pooh are walking together along one day
in an autumn forest
and when the pooh looks and says to
piglet
hey piglet what day is it today and
piglet
replies it's today and then winnie the
pooh says
ah that's right today that's my favorite
day
but dan doesn't like the tattoo because
it's next to a big scar from an
operation that he had i tried to get the
doctor to make the scar a little bit
closer so that i could put a balloon
on the top
yeah i guess this balloon would have
resembled the idea of keeping your head
in the clouds and your feet
on the ground by remembering that today
can be the greatest
or the shittest day of your life so yeah
to end it off i guess it's just about
embracing every day
oh what's wrong with that absolutely
okay well then how would you end it
without the bad days
then you can't appreciate the good days
anyways and if everyone just had good
days
then everyone would just be living their
best life and be the best at everything
talking about being the best at
everything there's only one brand that
comes to mind where you can really learn
it's my ending like this okay so anyways
like i said there's only one brand that
comes to mind and that's the sponsor of
today's video being skillshare
is an online learning community for
creators like me like you
like like gab sometimes where millions
come together to take the next step on
their creative journey
you don't even need to be creative if
you're curious if you just want to learn
skillshare has thousands of great
classes
i too have actually done a few classes
on there myself if i
yeah pretty proud of them most recently
filmmaking for all how to tell your
story and
the reason why i was you know tooting my
own horn there for a little bit
and just sucking in that affirmation is
because this class recently was rated
one of the
higher classes on skillshare so i'm
pretty proud
skillshare is built for lifelong
learners like myself and gabs and i'm
i'm pretty sure
you too so if you're interested click on
the link below and the first 1000
1000. that click on the link below get a
two-month free trial
of skillshare premium now wowzaroo
that's a real deal
just to give you some context a big news
channel here in south africa called card
blanche
is just about to arrive to interview
gabs and myself
obviously more about gabs and how cool
gabs is but
we were both highly offended that they
didn't ask joey to be a part of the
interview so what we decided to do
instead is have a competition to see who
can say
joey's name the most amount of times
during this interview to make him
the center point let's start at the very
beginning
joey joey joey joey joey
joey joey
let's just say we won't show joey
gabby's
dismal dismal performance
echo
i'm gonna have to talk softer so that
the echo doesn't attack us
before i sign this vlog out i just
wanted to to let you know to keep you in
the loop you know
keep this this friendship strong i'm
gonna be taking
10 days off of the vlog to
sleep mainly but but also build out
the space and yeah just just reflect
other than that with a lot of echo don't
forget
you're awesome brew and i'll see you in
next house
i'll see you in 10 days
[Music]
you